le cinéma n'est pas mort en Europe même
si les recettes des salles obscures
restent un tiers inférieure à ce
qu'elles étaient en 2019 avant la crise
sanitaire la tendance est plutôt à la
hausse depuis fin 2020 c'est en tout cas
ce que relève Gilles fontaine de
l'Observatoire européen de l'audiovisuel
plutôt en face de convalescence
c'est-à-dire que après évidemment le
covid
2021 avait marqué un rebond 2022 à
nouveau et les chiffres continuent à
s'améliorer également pour le début de
l'année 2023 mais avec évidemment des
différences entre entre pays on a noté
que la situation était très favorable
par exemple au Danemark en termes de
récupération qu'elle était moins
positive par exemple en Italie ou en
Espagne en Espagne les entrées ont ainsi
augmenté de 48% en France de 59% et de
241% en Lettonie une fréquentation des
salles de cinéma fluctuantes pour
différentes raisons il y a à la fois un
facteur d'offres c'est-à-dire que un
déficit de et notamment de films de
blockbuster américain qui a été ressenti
assez différemment dans les différents
pays européens et puis d'autre part
c'est vrai que un certain nombre de
consommateurs ou de spectateurs de
cinéma ont probablement un peu perdu
l'habitude d'aller au cinéma et que
c'est une habitude à recréer en fait
trois films de studio américain ont fait
revenir les spectateurs dans les salles
en 2022 Top Gun avatar et les minions
avec plus de 30 millions d'entrées
chacun des films dont le budget dépasse
largement ce des films européens comme
le souligne Martin kensler de
l'Observatoire européen de l'audiovisuel
je ne sais pas combien la production de
Top Gun a coûté mais en moyenne le
budget des films européens est de 2
millions d'euros ce n'est rien du tout
comparé au budget des films américains
donc évidemment les productions
américaines ont besoin de vendre
beaucoup plus de tickets pour
rentabiliser leur film l'industrie des
films européens n'a pas besoin d'avoir
le même nombre d'entrées pour rester
compétitive dans le sens où les
productions coûtent beaucoup moins cher
et les films européens s'en sortent bien
leur part de marché augmente même
passant de 26,8% à 28,4% en 2022